you know he's no
he's amazing to be like a spielberg yeah
he's a spielberg
yeah exactly so
uh i looked at joe and i go uh can i
pitch that thing he goes well we don't
have a we don't have a contract we
didn't say anything
pitch it and i pitched easter sunday to
them and they bought it in the room
they're like we'll take it i want that
movie spielberg wants that movie let's
do it and uh and we i go what about dan
lynn they go we'll call him if he wants
to join he'll join if not that's cool
we're doing it it was that fast we even
went to lunch and this is why i always
say this
celebrate every moment
right because people like we live in a
time now where everything's so fast
right and you want it now and if it's
not now then we can't celebrate right
right and that's that what is living
like why you're not even living at this
point like
like like when we left the the office
like we're hugging each other and we
both got emotional duh i cried and then
um
and joe was like well we'll see
what are you talking about we'll see
there's nothing else to see like this
was an amazing moment you know how many
people wished steven spielberg watched
their tape or even looked at their
headshot or gave a call like bro
celebrate this moment
like even if nothing happens four months
from now who gives a [ __ ] this moment is
this is an amazing moment and we get to
and we get to say it
and um so we got into a little fight we
even went to lunch and got into another
fight like dude stop like and he was oh
i'm just saying i know how hollywood is
i'm like stop
celebrate the moment let's eat and let's
enjoy this moment that we just had
and then right right when i said that
boom he gets a phone call from holly and
she's like yep just talk to dan we're
moving forward he's joining the team it
was that fast and who who wrote it
uh we got we got a bunch of uh writers
to write it and then we got my favorite
is uh jay chandrasekhar who uh
is you know he did all the he's broken
lizard he does uh all the super troopers
and all that stuff but uh also the
goldbergs he shoots that
and he came in and uh
and just took over and and directed the
movie for me so and you shot it we shot
it we it and then what was crazy is the
pandemic happened and i thought for sure
wasn't gonna happen i thought it was
done
and uh and then they got the call i got
the call they're like uh april we're
we're going we're going to vancouver to
shoot this movie and i was like oh my
god so this past april you were there we
just shot it yeah and i just got back
and when is it coming out
uh easter sunday 2022. and he wants a
theatrical release he doesn't want a
screaming release he wants a full-blown
theatrical release
red carpet everything was that not an
amazing story it's amazing not only the
story it's amazing
i think the way that you view life is
amazing to me
to me that was what i mean obviously to
shoot a movie and have that come out and
everything that's incredible steven
spielberg oh that's incredible but to me
what i take away from that is
celebrating each and every moment
because i think that's something i know
i struggle with i've seen you struggle
with that a lot in your business and
your career where you're like well we'll
see i don't know this happens all the
time so i think that that's a really
important lesson to take away from that
because people who think in another way
and i sometimes do with my ocd
it's also a protection yeah right so
the fear is if you celebrate that moment
and you're right if you celebrate that
moment yeah if that moment like joe
whoever was saying it to you if it
doesn't come to fruition yeah then
you're afraid of that disappointment
if i don't climb this high into my
emotions i don't have a long way to drop
but i also read that book like the power
of now yeah you know now is all we have
yeah what happened before is our
perception of it and memory and if there
were other people there they don't
remember it the exact same way and maybe
it didn't happen exactly the way you
remember it
what may happen in the future hasn't
happened yet the only thing that's real
is now the only thing we have is now
yeah and
that's those are words that i'm saying
and maybe somebody's listening to but
you live it yeah that's probably why
you are where you are like because
netflix said no to you first yeah so i'm
sure most people would be like well then
then no then it's no and i'm giving up
and you lived in the now i'm like no i'm
going to make it i'm not thinking about
what's going to happen later i'm doing
it now even if i made the decision to go
ahead and make it if i got that call
that you got you know i just want to i
want you to know that we're just not
interested yeah that might have stopped
me i know it would have stopped most
people
and the fact that you're able to go
through that what a great example you
are of humanity of perseverance of being
a father of being a friend these are
great this story that you just told i'm
so proud that you told that on here
because even the celebrating the moment
is what this is about and i'm looking at
people on the other side of the glass
and everybody was just you know
what an amazing story
[Music]
you